bon ce qui a été donné sur le smig c'est
une prime c'est pas une augmentation du
smic pour trouver des mesures et pour
nourrir les pauvres gens ou fait les
fonds de tiroirs des gens voyant
l'aéroport de paris l'année prochaine et
puis quoi encore on va privatiser la
justice a va privatiser les hôpitaux
je ne comprends pas comment vous pouvez
vendre nos biens ce qui rapporte à coup
sûr les thèmes sont variés la parole
franche et livre les gilet jaune
explorer doléances
face à eux les parlementaires écoute et
tente de défendre la politique
gouvernementale
si le ton monte un peu lorsqu'il s'agit
d'évoquer par exemple la rémunération
des hauts fonctionnaires
les échanges se font dans une ambiance
sereine je pense qu il faut en aucun cas
refuser le dialogue que le dialogue qui
est malgré tout maîtrisé qu'il a été
plutôt d'écouter les échanges ont été
vifs mais sans violence une rencontre
qui permet aux deux camps de
s'apprivoiser sans pour autant
progresser vers une sortie de crise le
problème c'est que des jeunes viennent
mais qu'ils écoutent les gens
et pas seulement d écouter prendre en
compte des revendications et un moment
donné les traduire par des décisions
concrètes au niveau le plus haut
aujourd'hui on en est pas là on n'est
pas à négocier
il y a eu des avancées importantes pour
le pouvoir d'achat qui ont été faites en
début d'année mais les demandes vont au
delà vont bien au delà sur le
fonctionnement démocratique de notre
pays
sur nos institutions et je pense qu'il
faut comprendre cette maman de cette
exigence
je crois qu'il est possible de faire
vivre et la démocratie représentative
est une expression directe de nos
citoyens les discussions durent près de
deux heures puis chacun repart avec ses
convictions à dijon une nouvelle
manifestation est prévue demain après
midi